[Music]
well for centuries freedom of speech has
been America's signature right it's what
sets us apart from other countries even
relatively free countries certainly the
rest of Europe and Canada but college
students aren't interested at all they
may not even know it exists a new survey
by Gallup finds that 53% of college
students say that having a diverse and
inclusive society is more important than
protecting free speech and culture as an
author and columnist in a hawk on free
speech she joins us to protects her and
me and the rest of us so in is it really
an either/or it's you can't have a
diversity inclusiveness well yes of
course you can we've had it for a few
hundred years what was strange about the
survey which I noticed immediately when
it landed in my inbox and it was odd
that the New York Times presented it as
if well we've covered all the bases here
is that the only breakdown they did age
breakdowns gender breakdowns political
party breakdowns the only ethnic
breakdown was black and white Americans
do they think we're living in the 1950s
because what is striking is this is of
course another problem of immigration
are two main immigrant groups Hispanics
and Asians overwhelmingly whether it's
the Pew Research Center Cato all kinds
of surveys done over the years show that
white and and black Americans
overwhelmingly support both free speech
and gun rights and you have almost the
reverse percentages with recent
immigrants I mean this idea that that
people come to our country and suddenly
think oh I understand yes you have a
right to speak even if I disagree with
you and even if you are insulting the
Prophet Mohammed no it doesn't work that
way so what you're seeing at places like
Berkeley
white students are only 30 percent of
the population at Berkeley Asian
students alone are 46 percent that's
more than black and white Americans
combined that's why you're getting the
biggest attacks on free speech at places
like Berkeley [ __ ] that's fast
social with a watch so it's not it's not
a left-right thing
as as much as it's a new arrival versus
born here things so then why wouldn't we
be doing everything we can to inculcate
our beliefs and understanding of our
rights under our Constitution in people
who just got here yes no you're right
well because we have we have even among
you know 11th generation Americans these
people called liberals and they're as
opposed to our fundamental freedoms as
the newcomers are but I mean the ACLU
has been surprisingly staunch on the
issue of free speech losing a lot of
their donors I might I might add in the
face of these recent attacks but you
would think that the ACLU would would
have an opinion on the importation of
people adamantly opposed to the mission
statement in their charter I mean we are
looking at the death of America's
fundamental freedoms as you said in your
introduction even England doesn't have
free speech well know it for America
both First Amendment and the Second
Amendment as this new generation of non
Americans grows up so why are our
corporations abetting this making it
worse Kroger the grocery chain announced
today that it will no longer stock
magazines that with photographs of
assault weapons not even clear how
they're defying that or what it's all
weapon is but scary-looking guns are no
longer allowed in photographs in Kroger
since when are companies sort of piling
on speech restrictions here well it's
been at least since Trump has come along
maybe before then but I just I I
returned to my to my refrain I don't
care what your opinion is on free speech
or guns or anything else but please stop
pretending you're a rebel
please stop you pretending you're
fighting the man when you are just
lockstep with corporate America these
are these new radicals we have the
resistance they'll they'll check with
corporate America you know Apple and
Twitter Facebook and their professors to
ask if they can wear a question
authority t-shirt without the okay
has there ever been a more obedient
little cadre of robots than college
students does anybody think is anyone
brave is anybody giving the finger to
the man and speaking the truth where are
those people what happened well the good
news is I'm following a lot of them on
Twitter I get the impression that we are
creating I mean on the left is creating
without realizing at this really
hilarious and ferocious generation of
right-wingers at these college students
you know they're listening to white
privilege all day every moment of every
day white heterosexual men are emerging
from college working at the moon right
wingers and they're a lot of fun to
follow on Twitter they're very I can't
imagine why maybe there are other tended
consequences to everything apparently
and culture thank you